ha hate talking to people about things
this is a nightmare
Oh grouchy mm-hmm we have to support Tom
think about it as role-playing that
makes it sexy that could be fun
can I use a weird voice and try to freak
people out yes okay and uh next time you
see me I'll be a stranger
there's just Leslie hey hey this is my
boyfriend Derek this is Derek's
boyfriend Ben hey oh wait sorry what's
the situation
what do you mean how does this work
Derek is gay but he's straight for me
but he's gay for Ben and Ben's really
gay for Derek and I hate Ben it's not
that complicated not oh yeah sure the
thing about youth culture is I don't
understand it man it costs $200 to get
certified I wanted to make fun of stupid
people while I get drunk my two true
passions what's with these fools
I will bankroll you really Oh sounds
like fun
Thank You April Ludgate professional
drinker where did you study miss lead
gates the wine Academy the wine Academy
in Bordeaux yes Carole make sure she's
in Group A I'm getting notes of dried
Robins blood old dirty cashews and just
a hint of a robot's bathwater mm-hmm
mighty buddy what are we doing we didn't
get a single thing that bent ones too
sure we did we got the marshmallow
shooter I think it's on the list
but I want it I want it too but I also
kind of want my own Fork just cuz you
eat really salt which is cute but also
super annoying fine
what what's wrong nothing it's just
adults are boring and I hate them and I
don't want to buy all this stupid boring
adult stuff and become boring adults hey
listen to me
yes we're gonna get a dish rack and
shower
curtains and a cutting board but if you
think for one second I'm not also gonna
get that marshmallow shooter so that I
can shoot you in the face with
marshmallows when you're asleep then
you're the dumbest woman I know gonna
make me cry
these are the Black Eyed Peas and I
finally killed them it's a Christmas
miracle hey hey so I was just at the
grind and I thought you might want an
iced mocha with extra extra whipped
cream
oh my thank you so much April Wow you're
welcome oh by the way completely
unrelated I just signed up for the Miss
Pawnee beauty pageant that's wonderful
you know that is why I decided to become
a judge so that awesome girls like you
who are not you know classically hot can
be rewarded for their intelligence and
savvy beauty pageants are idiotic but I
found out that the winner of the Miss
Pawnee pageant gets $600 I can be
idiotic for $600 so are you gonna vote
for me sister April it's unethical for
me to show you favoritism you and I are
like family
copies $7 yes right of course ladies and
gentlemen we are gathered here today to
marry Andrew Maxwell Dwyer and April
Roberta LED gate I guess I kind of hate
most things but I never really seemed to
hate you so I want to spend the rest of
my life with you
is that cool
what was your name Jennifer no its
tenifer with two y's it used to be
Jennifer but then I decided to rebrand
myself oh wait hang on it's an X o'clock
um
well nice to meet you my name is April
and I just wanted to say that your dress
is so cute it's bongs
I saw my spinning instructor wearing it
and I was like shut up where do I get
that oh my god who's your spinning
instructor Gregory or Monona I go to
Yanis who are Gregory and Winona I've
never heard of them before are they
better when Nona rocks my world
seriously you need to get me in there
like that's a must must must she's the
worst person I've ever met I want to
travel the world with her hello I'm
April Ludgate I'm 20 years old I like
people places and things and Pawnee is
my favorite place in the world I want to
be your assistant
really you hate it here so do you I'll
make sure you don't have to go to any
meetings if anyone comes to see you I'll
scare them away wait April if you had to
choose between these two ties you're
hired
I just figured I might as well get paid
for being here
hi champion oh my gosh there you are
that is a three-legged dog his name is
champion cuz he's the dog world's
champion
okay I have to ask this I'm sorry but
how many legs had that dog have when you
found him three that's what makes him
the best he can do more three legs than
most dogs can do with four except for
digging he's really bad at digging and
we remember what you said about making
decisions in the house you want to be
involved we get that so you just say the
word and champion goes back to the pound
where you can be put down and killed
brother can I send a three-legged dog to
his death
yes but I'm also not gonna take care of
him for you well it would be nice if you
helped a little
because unlike you and you and I have
jobs cruel but fair hey where are you
I'm here where are you we're inside the
main entrance you're the sign that says
quanti campground oh I'm in a totally
different place that's why we can't see
each other I don't even want to be here
the air is too fresh it's disgusting I
can't breathe there's a brook somewhere
that won't stop babbling shut up
sweetheart just hold tight and I'll be
there mm I both rats bats man parties
boom good spider webs done mm-hmm
fake blood capsules oh they didn't have
any really that's gross I love it we are
throwing a Halloween party at our house
is gonna be the greatest thing ever
someone will die um fun there's gonna be
beer pumpkins bloody goblin fake ones
it's gonna be awesome we have
decorations dead people that we just may
not murdered but pictures of dead people
from TV or movies body simple fake ones
candy
dancing tequila all kinds of food and
snacks let orphan no blood orphans I I
don't know what that is well we did it
we went to prom yay let's go now no what
are you kidding this is awesome
look around the bloom of youth like
flowers on the sunset of an Eagles
poetry Andy I hate teenagers
if you give this a chance you're gonna
love it I promise
it's like the movie Expendables 2 first
time hated it second time hated it third
time it was okay but then the fourth
fifth sixth time 10th time I watched it
I realized something it's just it's not
good it's not a good movie now that I've
convinced you why don't we go dance I'm
gonna go to the girls bathroom to check
the trash cans for babies but you can
dance if you want really I love you
thank you
well I've made a little progress I'm up
to four seconds with April hey April I
was looking to get some new music and I
was wondering if you could recommend
anything the Internet I really like your
haircut where'd you get it
prison how's your sister doing she has
the shingles who's your favorite
character on Sex in the City
Alf absolutely nothing what are you
wearing fine if you don't want to donate
then don't
oh by the way I'm calling come on what
April get in your peace won't do it I
don't care about that prize but I'm
gonna win because I want his happiness
to go away my love we have to go just
put all the candy in a bowl or something
what's wrong did you eat all the candy
no did you yes but this no what's wrong
it's just seeing all those kids out
there babe I want to put a babe in you
baby
Andy you know where I stand on this yes
I would love all the awesome stuff my
body would go through I mean if all I
meant was puking and getting weird
stretch marks and veins everywhere then
sign me up but at the end we've brought
a child into the world that's disgusting
deep wait why are you discussing stuff
off
you